data and simulation so today we're very
happy to have professor
monzer daley to give a talk on
his view of rl so uh professor daley is
a william coolidge professor at mit ucs
he's also the founding director for the
institute
of data systems and society at mit
so mulder has made a lot of fundamental
impacts across different domains
including
finance power i think transportation
and recently healthcare and he's leading
the kobe 19 emergency response group at
mit
okay so uh uh moser is uh i think
mueller is at heart
uh a control theorist so we're we're
going to hear
uh what's his view about rl as a control
theorist
thank you mcd um welcome uh good morning
everybody or
good afternoon for us on the east coast
let me share my slides
and um
[Music]
okay um so i would like to
make some cards you're in presenter mode
again
let me swap
better yes
perfect okay so um thanks
maybe for the invitation i'm uh excited
to speak to you today so i wanna
yes i think you're right i am a control
theorist i see
problems from the uh perspective of
controls
and so i thought today what i'll do is
i'll i'll tell you a little bit about
some of the
complexities that come up in learning
stochastic dynamical systems
particularly
uh when there's a mobile miss
specifications
and i want to tell you even though this
actually is not directly
reinforcement learning or adaptation i
want to
wrap the reinforcement learning around
this problem towards the end
to tell you what how one should be
thinking about these types of problems
so i will make the connection to the
towards the end so bear with me a little
bit in terms of um
how we get there um and i know i have 20
minutes 25 minutes ming d
25 25 minutes okay
this work is done in collaboration with
uh
my previous student who just graduated
to hin sarkar and
my colleague sasha racklin
so the problem is uh standard
we have uh we're learning a dynamical
system and then
from input output data so we think of
the inputs as sequences
between one to capital t we apply them
to a dynamical process
and we observe noisy outputs and the
question is can we learn this dynamical
system
it's really just sort of a fundamental
system identification question
um and the the real issue here is
well what do we know already about the
system
that enable us to learn this dynamical
system
the class of systems i want to look at
is stochastic switched linear systems
that this is a follow-up work on earlier
work that i talked about
and also was already got published in
the in jmlr
where we dealt with the linear time
invariant case so now we're dealing with
a jump
uh system that i'll describe in a second
so what is the system described by
so we have a state space representation
x is a vector of dimension
n okay and the um
the state evolves as a
linear jump system so it's a theta x of
t
where theta is sampled from an iid
probability distribution
so think of theta as being finite
support
there are basically s values of a at any
given time i pick one
of these values i evolve the system with
a sub
r and then the system evolves and then
the new state i sample again and i
evolve the system with a different a
okay so in a full description of this
dynamical system i would know the
dimension of the state space
i would know a1 up to a s i would know
the probability distribution of jumps
for theta
and of course i have the rest of the
system where
the input is affecting the state by some
matrix b
it's noisy and then the output is some
linear combination of the states
this is a simpler version of a general
switch linear system where
even the b and c matrices are also a
function of theta
this particular case i made it simpler
the input affects the state the same way
the observation of the output is the
same way and i'm just basically
um uh jumping the the transition matrix
a
okay so the system is fully described by
this quadruple if you like
the probability distribution piece of i
on that has support s
the set of a i's the b and c matrix
okay so that's a full description of a
system
and what we are trying to do is going
back to the learning problem and say
from input output data can we actually
reconstruct the system
okay that's the general problem when we
get to the specifics in a minute
now in this particular talk i am going
to assume
that not only i can measure inputs and
outputs but i can also measure
the transition theta sub i so
every time theta sub i is picked from
this
s values of a i know that this
transition have occurred
okay this is a simplification of course
in a general
uh system you may not have this data you
may have to estimate that data
that adds another layer of complexity to
the stochastic system
but in this talk i'm going to assume
that theta is measurable so for
measurable theta i
u i and y i how can i estimate the
dynamical system
described in this in this page okay
so that's kind of the general
description
problem i make some assumption of course
uh the first simplifying assumptions
just so that i can write down some
expressions
i'm gonna assume theta jumps between
only two variables
okay so there's only gonna be one and
two which means the transition
probabilities are the transition
state matrix is either peak a1 or a2
it's a two dimensional linear system in
this case
inputs are single input singular output
so u
is a is a single input b is a column
matrix
y is a is a single output which means c
is a roman
row matrix and then 8 and w are
gaussian noise that are uncorrelated
okay
we will make the assumption that this
stem is stable in a strong sense that
means that
if you look at the um response of the
system which is captured by
any one of these sequences if you
actually just for those people who are
not familiar with these types of
dynamical systems
if you look at the response of the
system what it looks like it looks like
you know convolution with terms that
look like this
okay it's c a l one to k
means that some sequence of of products
of a1 a2 a2 a1 you pick any sequence
of length k of uh
occurrences of of indices one and two
and you construct the product with these
matrices
that's a sub l1 to k okay any possible
combinations of that it kind of looks
like a
evolution of hidden markov model okay so
you have that and then you multiply by b
for stability of that system we're going
to assume that the sum
of the squares of these quantities is
finite and it's bounded by quantity beta
beta square beta square enters our error
bounds
but beta squared does not enter our
algorithms and so
knowledge of beta square is not
necessary to define the algorithms in a
minute
but it does actually define the error
balance of this problem
okay you look at the soup over all
possible sequences that way
so where is the challenge in this
particular problem
the first thing is that we are going to
collect only noisy data
that's kind of obvious and no system
identification problems with exact data
so that's easy
but it's a it's a it's a challenge the
important assumption here
is that the there's a the the
number of states the dimension of the
state space is unknown for this
particular problem so while in fact you
know that you're jumping between two
states
and you unders and you can measure that
so i'm assuming that the
jumps are known but i do not know the
dimension of the state space so i don't
know in this
in in the setting the dimension of the
latent variables
okay so the latent variables are unknown
they could be arbitrarily high
which means that the system has very
very high memory
okay system could have very low memory
there's no prior
on that order and then there is no
distribution on that order there's just
no knowledge of that particular order
and of course the final thing is that in
state space this parameterization tends
to be non-convex in terms of the
description of the c the ai's and the b
okay so what we're trying to do is learn
the system
and i would say the misspecification
problem or the robustness
problem has to tackle the question of
this unknown hidden state
unknown dimension of the latent variable
i would say if you have an upper bound
then you at least learn assuming that
particular upper bound it may be
expensive but at least
mathematically you you would say i would
learn for that upper bond but here there
is no upper bound known
no knowledge of that particular state so
this is kind of the key
issue for for this learning problem and
it kind of applies the same way for the
linear time and variant case
with a little bit more complexity in
this case of jump linear systems
okay so let me describe the data
the data is going to be a bunch of
rollout and and
samples so what we're going to do is
that we're going to run
multiple experiments and the reason
we'll run multiple experiments we want
to make sure that we are generating
all the interesting sequences of of
products a iag okay because what is
happening remember as i did the
simplification that i only have two
transitions a1 and a2 at any given time
either i sample a1 and sample a2
so i need to make sure that i get many
as many of them as possible
so i'm going to run n sub s different
experiments each experiment and we're
going to roll for end time
okay so they're all our time length is
going to be n the sample complexity
the number of experiments i'm going to
run is ns and the budget i have at the
end of the day
is n s times n that's the time period
that i have this is the total length of
the whole experiments that i have
okay so that's the data was generated
and of course all the observations are
going to be noisy because as i said the
underlying assumption of the model is
that is
disturbed by noisy data so the outputs
are going to be noisy
but i do have access to the experiment
so i know you i
and i know why i and i know uh the the
jumps
the that the system goes through
so here's the high level story that um
you know coming back to make this uh
comment about being a control theorist
he is the control theory piece
of this problem okay so um
i have an m which is a process i don't
know
the dimension of the state space i don't
know the size of the latent variable
that means that if i have finite data i
cannot guarantee you that i can learn
m m can be much higher order than the
dimension of the data
so right away if i'm trying to come up
with an algorithm
that estimates m with with small error
you know that that's not going to be
possible
okay not going to be possible with
robustness because m
could have come the data that i measured
could have come from arbitrarily high
dimensional system that requires
arbitrarily long
data set so refinite said i cannot do
that okay
but what can i do if i cannot learn the
actual system what can i do
well i should be able to learn some
lower
dimensional approximation of m
okay that some lower dimensional
approximation the
the dimension of that approximation
should be driven from the data that i
collected
okay so the data should dictate a
dimension
r that says learn an all-dimensional
part of the system
so what does that mean from a control
theory perspective it means that
you really have to learn you really have
to learn
the best r dimensional approximation of
m
okay so let's say that there's a
theoretical best
lower dimensional approximation of of m
then what i need to do is learn that
estimate that part
okay so that's kind of the trick data
should tell me
some dimension r for which i can
actually
learn the best lower dimensional
approximation of f
all right now the nice thing about this
in control theory for this class of
system is that the characterization
of mr if m was known is actually
possible and is done through
a construct that known as the hankel
hankel matrix
and so the hankel matrix of m captures
all lower dimensional approximations of
m
so in principle what we need to do is
approximate the hankel matrix
of m find the r-dimensional
approximation of the hankel matrix
construct construct the r-dimensional
approximation
of mr and then see if that works
okay so that's kind of the mental
exercise so i need to design again
independent estimator m-hat of
r as a function of t
where r is really a function of t the
dimension of that approximation is a
function of t
that's the crux of the argument so what
i'm going to do now is i'm going to tell
you what this heinkel matrix is
how i get h hat and then and then how
what what bound that enables me to get
in terms of how do i actually find
r that will provide me with a guarantee
of for that system and what i'm saying
is that as you observe more and more
data
those numbers may change r depends on t
h
hat depends on t and then you continue
to improve your estimation based on t
but for a given size of t you may settle
with a much lower dimensional
approximation than the original
system okay what is the ankle line mean
the height and matrix or the handkerlike
matrix the helical matrix for linear
timing versus invariant system is easier
than
for this switch linear system or a jump
linear system
but basically it looks like this it's a
product of
a column matrix times a row matrix the
column matrix is often referred to as
the observability matrix
okay and they kind of have this
particular form
it has c which is the output matrix
and then c times all the possible
sequences
of possible occurrence of jumps so you
get a1 alone
you get a2 alone you get a1 squared you
get a1 a2 you get a2 a1 and you continue
to do that for arbitrarily length
it'll be then a1 a2 a1 a1 a2
a2 you know and so forth and you keep
doing that you can enumerate that elixir
graphic
order and add you know and sort of
kind of target with a an integer so you
do an
ordering lexographic ordering and you
write this particular matrix called the
observability matrix
the product of this observability matrix
times another matrix called the
reachability matrix which looks like
a transpose of the other one and
basically maps the input to the state so
you got an
input to the state state to the output
and that's the hankel matrix
okay this is now a theory about model
reduction and it says that you can
construct this hankel matrix if you knew
the actual parameters of the system
they're all scaled by the way
by the probabilities of the occurrence
of
of that particular a sub i okay so if
you have a1 you multiply by square root
of p1 if you write
a1 a2 you multiply by the square root of
p1 times b2
okay so that's how you construct a
matrix from the theoretical
description from the from the exact
description of a process you can also
shift it by one or by two depending
whether you want to shift it by a1 and
a2
by multiplying by that particular matrix
and when i cut a long story short and i
tell you
there's a theory behind how this hackled
matrix connect
to two things one is the minimum
realization
of that particular stochastic process
and two
an approximation of that stochastic
process and the way it works is
basically doing a
singular valley decomposition of the
hankel matrix
there's a nice property with this hackle
matrix that no matter how complicated
the system
it always has finite rank okay
and the rank of that matrix is exactly
equal to the dimension of the latent
variables
so what is the really the the reason the
hankel is interesting
is that it is capturing in it
a statistic that will estimate the rank
of the underlying system
but more strongly so so the first thing
is that the minimum realization is
obtained
by doing a a singular value
decomposition of this particular matrix
but actually one can do more and say by
taking
only the top singular values of the
hackle matrix you obtain
lower dimensional approximations of the
original system
it's easy to see that you can
approximate the hankel matrix
what is not obvious is that in the
approximate ankle matrix
there correspond a dynamical a
stochastic dynamical system
of order k that actually approximate the
original system this is a very strong
resulting control theory
which is out of the context of this talk
over here
so my program is really simple i'm going
to use the data to estimate
edge i cannot estimate all of edge
because it's an infinite matrix i'm
going to have to estimate a block of
h and then from the singular value
decomposition of h i'm going to prove
all the results that i have
okay and the point is i'm going to be
able to do everything with
with time varying by with with time
dependent bonds
okay i cannot learn all the matrix
i know it has finite rank but i don't
know the rank so i cannot look for it it
could grow with the
as the data grows um and so i need to
construct an
estimate so one particular way and i
begin this is maybe a lot of knowledge
of
model reduction in control theory a
hankel matrix is
described in terms of the mapping
between past input to future outputs
so there is a very quick way using the
data to estimate the parameters of the
hackle matrix
because it has it has that mapping from
past inputs to future outputs
but i can align the inputs and output in
such a way that i can estimate the
parameters of the hackle matrix so so i
do that
the interesting question for us is how
do i pick the size
of the hank of the of the hankel block
how do i pick n in the hankel block
if i picked n then the i would get
an estimate h hat of n it has a block
size n and that
should compare to the infinite handful
matrix which i don't know
and if i use the triangular inequality
that gives me two pieces h n
okay is is um i can i can add and
subtract the
actual truncation of n dimension of h
infinity
and then what i have is the following my
estimate
should be approximating the actual
truncated
hn of the original hackle matrix
and what's left should be a truncation
error
the truncation error is what i did not
know and this error is the
estimation error based on the data that
i got so what i'm trying to do is
actually provide a probabilistic bonds
for both of these
quantities this one i can estimate from
the data and this one i can force
based on how i pick an and the upper
bound on the
on the total norm of my process
so two things i will tell you about and
i know i'm getting close to running out
of time
the first thing is that how do you pick
the size of the hackle matrix
that means how do you pick how do you
pick
um uh so the size of the hackle matrix
is is very closely related to
how many sequences of a sub i
occurred okay so that means that as i'm
looking at it you know
um i'm looking at the data and i'm
measuring theta sub i right i'm looking
at
um if i look at sequences of of length
five
how many so so that means that i any
possible
uh combination of length five could have
happened
i want any any combination of those to
have occurred multiple times if it only
occurred once
then my learning algorithm is not going
to do very well so i need
the the k-th order
the number of case order sequences that
occur to be larger than a certain
threshold
that is i have richness in the data so
sequences say a1
a2 or a2 a1 these are sequences of
length 2
occur at least five times you know so
the threshold
is defining that the threshold is only a
function of a constant c
okay and what i would pick n to be to be
the smallest k
the smallest length that such that the
sequences of that length occur
higher than a threshold that means that
i have some confidence in my estimation
algorithm
and if i did that i could then go to my
regression i estimate my hackle matrix
with dimension 2 and up
upper bound and then what i'll do is
i'll do a thresholding of this
particular
um hackle matrix that i estimated over
here
from the regression i will threshold it
through also a data dependent bond okay
and to estimate what the order of the
dynamical system i want to pick
so what i'll do is i'll say look okay i
have a threshold
for a second let's just think of that as
a constant i'm going to look at the l
singular value divided by the first
singular value to be larger than the
threshold
as l increases this quantity decreases
and this bond may not occur
okay so at some point ls will stop and i
will take the largest l for which the l
divided by sigma is larger than the
threshold and i would say
that's r that's my data driven
dimension of the system that i would
need to estimate
to guarantee a reasonable bond over my
error
so i pick that based on this quantity
and i get this particular guarantee with
high probability
and the guarantee with high probability
says that all the parameters in this
case my c
and and and b were constant so this is
irrelevant
in this tall but my a1 is approximated
by a1 hat and a2 is approximately by a2
hat
and these approximations i will get to
be
as close as sigma 1 divided by sigma l
of the estimated angle matrix times an
error that decays as one
over the fourth root of ns
remember ns is the number of experiment
is the sample complexity
so the number of experiments increase i
decrease this error by a fraction of 1
over root
and s but the bond is multiplied by how
well
my data is which is a time dependent
bond over here of course you can look at
the synthetic results and everything
works well
but this is a finite data result okay
so that's kind of in a nutshell what you
what what this result is
is about it really allows you to say uh
in principle start with your approximate
handles
find an upper bound on what the size of
the handle that you want to approximate
is from the data okay do a thresholding
through singular value decomposition and
then and estimate a truncated
lower dimensional system that's really
the algorithm
the point of this is that you can
actually so the
the the interesting aspect of this is
that all these bonds
are derived from the data itself okay
and so of course they may not be great
but that's what the data has given you
but it always tells you that there is
always a lower dimensional
system that does really well at least
in estimating the the best lower
dimensional approximation of the
original system
okay and here's just a quick example
where just to show kind of why this
happens so this is basically what we
refer to as a finite impulse response
system
it's um you know the c and b were picked
randomly
and i have a decaying system of rho to
the power k
okay but otherwise there's uh the
impulse response of the system is zero
above one fifty so this is a finite
impulse response system
and this example shows you that if you
follow this particular algorithm
you find out that you know the
uh a system of dimension four turns out
to do so much better
than a system of dimension 16 you know
that the hankel matrix actually settles
into a very low dimensional problem
for that size of data which in this
particular case 5 50
50 000 data points for this example they
use 50 000 data points
and stop there's no asymptotics in that
then the best order model
does is probably four you can argue okay
eight
is also doing really well because it's
kind of ultimately
drops below a certain value but the
point is that if you increase the data
points
you're you're in this range over here
while for example a 16th order system
which is you know the original process
is 150
or the system but a fourth order system
is giving us the best approximation of
that
process so the the algorithm naturally
picks
the best lower dimensional approximation
so how is this related to
the reinforcement learning it's really
interesting
in that um the way you want to think
about this is that suppose the
underlying dynamical system
is very high dimensions unstructured no
knowledge of
the parameterization of m but you're
wrapping a control strategy around it
and every time the control strategy is
optimized to minimize a certain cost
function right but the point is
what you would do at every step is you
will will do
a similar thing that i did before which
is
um split the error into an estimation
error and a truncation error
okay and give a bound electronication
error and if that bond exceeds a certain
threshold you may want to increase the
dimension of r
okay so r in this reinforcement learning
now
is not fixed but rather moves up with
the data so there's a
data varying dimension of the underlying
system for which you do the
sort of the the redesign of the control
then as you have the new experiment
you re-estimate the car and you continue
the process and this is ongoing work
that we
we have right now and trying to make
this work for the reinforcement learning
problem
so um with that i'm i stop here because
i know that i've
already exceeded my time and thank you
for the attention
thank you mother very nice talk you
think nanjing has a question
can you can you speak yeah hi
uh master thanks for the uh great talk
so i just want to
mention that uh so in rl people have
looked at
uh very similar algorithms but for
discrete observation discrete action
partially observable systems where we
also use spectral learning for
uh you know building on observable
handheld matrices
and people also in the last past few
years have been looking at how to
you know do low-rank approximations of
them and one interesting thing
i'm thinking from there is that uh
there's some interesting result that
says that you can afford to
use as large ankle matrix as possible
even if the
entries for very long sequences that
you're estimating extremely poorly
but if you look at how you recover the
spectrum properties
of the entire matrix it it has some
dimension free properties and we also
observed that
in you know empirically in practice so i
was just curious if something
similar could happen for linear
dynamical systems
as well where your concentration bounds
wouldn't need to you know depend on any
form of like the size of the
tentacles that's a great question so if
that i mean i've seen
quite a bit of that work but if there's
more please send me some references
and would love to take a look in more
detail so i think you're right
actually in the linear time invariant
system i could ignore
the the the definition of n sub u
which i i you know and and keep the
hackle matrix arbitrarily high
arbitrarily high and then do the
thresholding correctly because the
thresholding gets rid
of some of the stuff right so for the
bounce
to prove the bounce we need and you in
practice
i can just do it and and threshold and i
get the same results
but you know so you know i would still
have to say that i can guarantee you
as much as this error so i do that
counting for the bond
but i don't need it for the algorithm
you see what i'm saying so you know
you're right i can just estimate the
largest possible ankle matrix i have
and some of the tail stuff is out there
and i can get rid of it
in in these in the thresholding process
but the thresholding depends on my n sub
u
is what i'm saying so it depends on that
on that particular estimate
it's a great question thanks and i i've
already put one
reference in the chat i'll put a few
more okay that's fantastic thank you so
much yeah
so i have a question so for accurately
as making a long-range approximation to
the hanker matrix
we will need some assumption on the data
right the data should
cover enough about the state space so
would there be some bad examples in
which for example
there are certain states that are that
happen to be hard to reach
but we have to collect information from
those states to isolate
the low-rank matrix as well so in that
case
would that cause an issue for the
algorithm and is there anything to get
around with it
so the algorithm is not tuned to beta
it doesn't care about beta the bond
depends on beta right so data is
is the the bond on the on the say on the
input output mapping
right so kind of like think of it as the
total gain of the system
so beta enters the bounds but it doesn't
you know it's not changing the algorithm
so
of course if i want to improve on that
beta i may have if beta was very very
high of course the bonds are really bad
and so i need to do more
but what is interesting mainly is that
because i am
capturing the best lower dimensional
approximation if there are states in
that system
that are there but they don't contribute
a lot to the gain i'll just ignore them
because they the lower dimensional
approximation of that system
also ignores them if they don't
contribute large
if they contribute high values to beta
then they would be captured in the
my first singular values of the of the
system so that's why i'm saying that
mapping connecting this model reduction
story to the approximation story through
is really
critical because it finds the dimension
the directions
that are the most important for you
through the hankel matrix
we could have just done any basis
approximation but this is nicer
because it guarantees that what you get
is the best input
output approximation of the system so
kind of naturally
sorts out through the higher the the
most impactful
impactful state i don't know if that
answered your question
yeah i think partially yeah thank you so
uh we might have more questions
but we have to defer those to the break
you could stay for a bit longer no
problem
okay so um so big d i think i'm
introducing alex is that right